I could not resist so I had to look it
up from the office of national
statistics from a 2019 study in ever
increasing numbers we are now at a
lesbian divorce rate of 72% so the top
four reasons that they are reporting
getting divorced is feeling ignored
inequality in the partnership adultery
and domestic violence personally I Feel
Like This lends some weight to men's
arguments and complaints about how women
are behaving in relationships because
when you have lesbian statistic lesbian
divorce statistics that look like that
the girls are kind of telling on
themselves but how are the yeah the
lesbians are getting divorced cuz they
don't like men anymore so they leave
their husbands right that makes sense to
me I I wouldn't I'd be surprised if the
lesbians were more likely to stay are
they is this lady referring to two women
together as a as a marriage or a divorce
it doesn't make any sense